قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ب بنيامين
نتنياهو ان ما وصفه باصراره هو الذي حال
دون قيام دوله فلسطينيه لسنوات طويله وانه
سيواصل التمسك بذلك طالما بقي رئيسا
للوزراء وقال نتنياهو انه اوضح للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن تصميم اسرائيل على
تحقيق اهداف الحرب في غزه وسحق حركه حماس
وان القطاع سيبقى منطقه منزوعه السلاح
وتحت سيطره امنيه اسرائيليه كامله وكذلك
كل الاراضي الواقعه غرب نهر الاردن حسب
تعبيره غزه يجب ان تكون منزوعه السلاح
وتحت السيطره الكامله لدوله اسرائيل ولن
اتنازل كذلك عن السيطره الامنيه
الاسرائيليه الكامله على كل الاراضي
الواقعه غرب الاردن بصفه رئيسا لوزراء
اسرائيل فقد وقفت بثبات الى جانب هذا
الموقف في مواجهه الضغوط الدوليه
والداخليه الكبيره اصراري هو الذي حال دون
قيام دوله فلسطينيه لسنوات طويله والتي
كانت ستشكل خطرا وجوديا على اسرائيل
وطالما باقيت رئيسا للوزراء ساواصل التمسك
بذلك بحزم